Hey guys!
Right before the pandemic struck, Julia and
I made a very special episode we're excited
to finally share with you.
We visited a financial therapist to discuss
a challenge we've struggled with for years.
Now if we did this today, we'd probably do
it outdoors with masks, and have a lot of
different issues to talk about.
But we still think it's relevant to consider
how your emotional history impacts your financial
decision-making.
Spoiler alert: I get a little weepy.
Julia and I have worked professionally as
financial advisors for many years.
Over that time, we've helped a lot of clients,
expanded our knowledge base, and started a
popular YouTube show.
But one thing we've never done is raise our
fees.
That's right, nervous newbie Julia and Philip
charged the same rates as experienced, confident
Julia and Philip.
We've talked about it for a long time but
it just feels so weird.
Like, I think we're worth it, but for some
reason, it's really scary to pull that trigger.
So on this special episode of Two Cents, we've
decided to turn the tables and get help from
someone else.
Oh, and you can lose the background, we won't
be needing that.
We're here at the office of Michelle Bohls,
a therapist who specializes in the emotions
that money can cause in people's lives.
I'll admit it, I'm a little nervous.
I mean, I'd like to think that we're pretty
financially savvy, but you never know what
can come up once you start digging.
Just remember, whatever happens is between
you, me and the therapist.
Right.
And our hundreds of thousands of subscribers.
Good point.
Let's go inside.
Hi!
I'm Michelle!
I'm Julia.
Thank you so much for having us here today,
Michelle.
We are excited and nervous.
So, what is it you actually do?
Well, so, I'm a financial therapist, specifically
helping couples work with money in their relationship.
And a financial therapist is not a financial
person that's gonna sit down with your bills
or your budget or tell you what to do with
your money.
But really looking at the belief systems that
you're bringing in about the money, and why
you as a couple might get stuck on particular
decisions.
My dad was a CPA, my parents were both very
poor.
I just naturally gravitated towards understanding
money.
But then, seeing couples--and money's such
a typical issue for couples.
And it can be hard to talk about, because
there's this idea of being not a polite topic
in lower socioeconomic circles or middle class.
But the upper class, the 1%, will talk about
money quite comfortably and with their children.
And they'll educate them about money.
And so, a lot of us come out into the world
without the information we need about money.
Okay, so, Michelle, what should we expect
as we go into this session?
We've never been in a financial therapy session
before.
Um, I can tell you I don't know what to expect,
because I've never been in a therapy session
with the two of you before.
So we're all kind of in it together.
Okay, we're learning as we go.
And all I can tell you is, we all get stuck.
And it's really just, do you have a few tools
to get unstuck.
We're excited.
Yeah, I think we're ready.
Okay, great, well let's start then.
Money gets to the heart of our sense of safety.
It's often associated with different types
of threats.
It's either threatening to make it, it's threatening
to spend it or it's threatening to save it.
And there's all kinds of things that we do
avoid feeling those fears that are connected
to money.
So, when I think about raising our fee, I
worry like we'll just be for rich people.
And I don't wanna be.
You worry that by raising our fees, we won't
be able to help as many people.
Is that right?
Yes.
Just see if you can remember anything from
your history where you started to get the
idea that some people have money and some
people don't have money, and that something
is nefarious about it.
Yeah.
I think... this is kinda random why I think
of this, but I remember growing up, my dad,
he was a used car salesman.
He one year won a trip to Hawaii because he
was such a great salesperson.
And his boss took it from him.
The owner of this big car dealership who had
all the money that he could've possibly wanted,
he took that vacation from my dad.
So when I think about that man, the story
I make up about him is...
I think, the story that I make up about that
man is that his wealth made him blind to the
needs of others.
I remember how mad my mother was.
My mom was-- she wasn't mad about the loss
of this trip.
She was mad about how poorly he'd been treated.
When we see that other people have money or
don't have money, that also generates a lot
of feelings in us.
We can feel greedy, like we need more.
We can feel deprived, like we don't have enough.
We can feel ashamed of what we have.
We can feel envy for what they have.
So really money is a very emotional topic
for all of us.
When I think about raising our fees, I have
a couple feelings.
One of them is... um... a feeling of being
corrupt.
I mean, I'm really worried of what people
will think of us.
Even talking about it, not even doing it.
Maybe, are you worried about, like, our fans
and our subscribers thinking...
Yeah.
And the story I make up is that they will
think...
The story I make up is they will think we
are... predatory and frauds.
I definitely started to feel some changes
in how I was thinking about ideas of integrity
and corruption.
Saying how we feel about this together with
somebody else in the room, just kinda made
it less intimidating, less shameful.
When I first became a financial advisor, my
first job, I saw advisors who were older than
me doing things and selling things that, to
my mind, looked like they only helped out
the advisor and didn't help out the person
on the other end.
And do you now think that this is equivalent
to doing that?
Mm hm.
Or could be.
Could be. Could be. Good.
All of our stories come from our history.
That we really can't come from anywhere but
our own experiences.
I mean, we have an imagination, but when it
comes to emotional things, it's usually from
our memory, our memory networks.
The stories that our minds make up, we call
those projections.
And when your past creates projections, that
blocks connection for the couple.
When I was younger, I was really into literature,
and loved to read the classics.
And in so many stories, the evil, corrupt
character is the wealthy one.
It was part of the reason I decided to become
an artist and study art in school.
That seemed like the exact opposite direction.
I knew I'd be poor but true to myself, if
I ran away from a lucrative career.
It's a very primitive fear.
If we're all living in a village, right? And
I'm hoarding food and water while you're starving...
You're gonna come kill me.
And that's really--that was the correct response.
That's how some of our ancestors got here.
So, understanding that when we have more,
there is a threat level, you know, to having
more when other people don't have.
But especially if we saw anyone get hurt by
that dynamic as a child.
As an adult, when I look at that decision...
I have a hard time trusting myself.
I trust you.
I trust you more than I trust myself.
When I see you being decisive, I feel more
confident.
What comes up for me hearing you say that?
When I hear you say that, um, it worries me.
I get a little anxious about whether I am
making right decisions.
So in those moments what I might need from
you...
In those moments, what I might need from you
is to hear
that it'll be okay if I don't make the best choice sometimes.
That if I make a mistake, that you can still
trust me.
I actually did find it quite surprising that
we were looking at each other, that she was
not giving us advice to do this or don't do
this, because that's what an advisor does.
I would say she created a safe emotional place
to talk about non-safe ideas.
Working with Julia and Philip in that session,
I'm noticing, okay, there's like a lot of
strengths here.
They're able to listen to each other, be curious.
Whichever way they decide to go, I know that
their relationship's better for having learned
where some of the energy was coming from.
Yay!
Thank you!
Thank you very very much.
Thank you, Michelle.
Because of our work, Philip and I are already
pretty used to discussing money issues openly
with each other, but most couples struggle
to get on the same financial page.
You might disagree with your partner about
spending priorities, get frustrated with their
tendency to save too much or not enough, or
harbor resentment about different income levels.
Finance and therapy are two things that have
unfortunate stigmas that might discourage
people from getting the help that could alleviate
their problems.
We hope that watching us go through this will
make it seem a little less intimidating for you.
And that's our two cents!
Thanks to our patrons for keeping Two Cents financially healthy!
Click the link in the description to become a Two Cents patron.